tél
bonjour à tous bienvenue en europe hebdo
votre rendez vous d'actualité européenne
ici au parlement européen à bruxelles au
programme de cette émission l'europe
face à la menace terroriste
près de six mois après les attentats de
paris et un mois après les attentats de
bruxelles comment l'union européenne
peut elle lutter contre ce fléau
alors que le fichier pnr passenger name
record qui doit recenser les
déplacements aériens enfin été votée par
le parlement lors de la dernière session
plénière cet outil sera t-il suffisant
faut-il comme certains le réclament déjà
un fbi à européen
mais d'abord avant d'en débattre avec
mes invités retour sur les ratés des
services de renseignement et de police
dans le cadre de l' enquête a tout de
suite
22 mars 2016 8 heures du matin une
double explosion provoquée par des
kamikazes ravages l'aéroport de
bruxelles zaventem
moins d'une heure plus tard c'est au
tour de la station de métro de malbec à
300 mètres des institutions européennes
bilan 30 personnes décédées plus de 270
blessés fomenté depuis molenbeek et
schaerbeek dans la banlieue de bruxelles
ces attentats plonge la belgique dans
l'horreur quelques mois après les
attentats de paris
ce que nous redoutions s'est réalisé
notre pays et nous concitoyens te
frapper l'enquêté détermine rapidement
que c'est la même équipe qui est à
l'origine des deux attentats les
arrestations se succèdent tout comme les
révélations sur les ratés des services
de renseignement
face à ce fiasco les ministre belge de
l'intérieur et de la justice ont
présenté leur démission refusée par
charles michel les des bateaux belgium
bashing dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme dans tous les pays dont le
monde et en europe
il y a eu des succès il ya eu des échecs
il ya eu de grands succès en belgique
nous avons empêché de nombreux attentats
plus de 100 condamnation plus de 100
condamnation l'année passée en un an
en matière de terrorisme concurrence des
services de sécurité nationaux manque de
coopération des renseignements lenteur
des prises de décision les constats sont
les mêmes de bruxelles à paris
probablement qu'il y a encore des
améliorations apportées à notre système
de partage d'informations et de
renseignements
face à la menace terroriste les
capitales sont donc condamnés à coopérer
et à s'entendre
et pour en parler je reçois gilles de
kerchove bonjour vous êtes le
coordinateur à la lutte antiterroriste
ici au sein de l'union européenne
bienvenue à vous à côté de vous jean
arthuis vous êtes député européen membre
du groupe libéral démocrate et président
de la commission des budgets bienvenus
bon je vais enfin en face de vos
philippe lambertz vous êtes co président
du groupe des verts ici à dans ce
parlement
messieurs je voudrais d'abord revenir un
petit peu sur cette enquête
comment est ce que vous expliquez à ce
point c'est raté ça a quand même été
pointé un nombre de fois c'est important
que ce soit sur les attentats de paris
puis à bruxelles comment est ce qu'on a
pu à ce point ne pas communiquer entre
nos services il de car comme moi je
trouve que c'est trop tôt pour tirer des
conclusions il y aura des commissions d
enquête qui permettront déterminé moi je
ne tire pas du tout le nécessairement le
la conclusion qui a eu des ratés dans
l'échangeur enseignements si vous
regardez par exemple ce qui s'est passé
à paris avec charlie hebdo est ce que
c'était eu un problème de dos n'est pas
nécessairement c'était ok c'est une
question d' analyse donc j'ai pour moi
très important de dans l'est dans les
semaines à venir de pouvoir tirer les
bonnes conclusions
cela étant dit il est clair qu'on doit
intensifier les changes et intensifier
l'analyse vous êtes d'accord mais pour m
là j'ai beaucoup de respect pour gilles
de kerchove mais très franchement quand
salle abdeslam est arrêté au péage
d'hordain et que la police française qui
dit circulez ya rien à voir
parce qu'elle n'a pas été informé par la
police belge que c'est un suspect d'
actes de terrorisme
j'ai dit il ya quand même un petit
problème de communication la formation
quand el batraoui revient en europe de
turquie que les services turc informe
les services belges et les services
néerlandais attention il ya un gars
dangereux qui est en train de revenir
le type dit non non je veux pas revenir
en belgique c'est trop dangereux veut
passer par les pays-bas ok fait ça et
sur les trois heures et demie du vol
les hollandais n'ont pas le temps de
dire brin tiens on va peut-être aller le
cueillir et on va le laisser partir en
belgique
qu'on me dise qui est peut-être pas
problème de partage d'informations moi
ça me semble crever les yeux que cette
logique du chacun pour soi à l'intérieur
des états membres les services qui ne
communiquent pas entre eux et entre les
états membres c'est en tout cas un
élément évitant des faillites de la
lutte anti terroriste en europe le
deuxième est évidemment celui et là je
suis assez d'accord avec avec gilles
deguire cours de l'exploitation du
renseignement canton à dur
saignement on n'a pas les moyens moyens
jeudi alors oui jean arthuis c'est un
problème d'homme ou c'est un problème de
volonté politique
ça aurait de moyens oui de moyens
résulte d'un problème de volonté
politique incontestablement mais nous
sommes dans un espace européen et le
fractionnement de l'espace judiciaire
c'est le rêve de tous les délinquants de
tous les criminels de tous les
terroristes parce qu'effectivement pour
eux il ya pa 28 états il ya un seul
territoire et le fait de pouvoir
franchir une frontière pour échapper à
des poursuites
celle idéal pour les délinquants et par
ailleurs l'absence d' échanges
d'informations au 21ème siècle alors que
les des capacités numériques nous donne
des moyens sans précédent
cette cette attitude des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement parce qu'il reçoive
l'onction démocratique au plan national
la sq elle selon vous jean arthuis pour
être clair c'est que les chefs d'état le
gouvernement ne veulent pas transmettre
en fait cette capacité parce que si on
est dans le domaine du régalien il est
hors de question on se souvient on ne
lâche rien
parce que on veut être celui qui
détiendrait les prérogatives de
souveraineté nationale de kharkov ses
moyens en quoi on donne en spectacle
trop souvent l'impuissance politique
mais c'est ça qui déchaîne le populisme
on a retrouvé en cherchant un petit peu
dans nos archives et bien une interview
commune qui avait fait garde fraudeurs
et jacques chirac
il y a de cela dix ans après les
attentats de londres où déjà à l'époque
il nous parlait d'un et ce billet
européen qui est revenu donc il y a
encore révélé le jour voilà exactement
il ya encore quelques jours dans le
débat on réécoute
nous allons renforcer le plan d'action
européen contre le terrorisme nous
l'avons notamment d'évoquer ce matin
nous allons mieux encore coordonner nos
services de renseignement et de police
et aussi nos justice on est à l'heure
des comptes secrets je suis d'accord
avec le président chirac
la lutte contre le terrorisme exige que
nous mettions en commun toutes les
énergies nécessaires alors c'est quand
même fou c'était il y a dix ans et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui face à un serpent
de mer qui n'a absolument pas changé
comme l'antique exactement rien debout
mais je vous préviens de ces faits et a
fait de la chute est de 1500 en a eu
chez les cas on l'a dit j'ai deux cas
cela dit quand bien même on décide déjà
des mesures de partage d'informations on
n'exécute pas et c'est vrai que vous
l'avez vous l'avez dit on touche au
domaine du régalien et donc c'est
extrêmement sensible pour ce domaine
ouvrez là sont les chefs de gouvernement
et les normes et man 2 maintenant il y a
évidemment un souci qui est souvent mis
en avant oui mais si on partage les
informations qu'on a et qu'elle tombe
dans de mauvaises mains
parce qu'en fait on n'a pas vraiment une
confiance absolument inébranlable de
l'étanchéité des services de
renseignements de tous les états membres
et je peux comprendre alors on utilise
souvent cet argument là pour dire alors
on ne partage pas vous comprenez mais là
je pense que peut t'arriver qu'au plan
national on ne partage pas d'information
non plus la vie active il ya concurrence
et on l'a vu en france la concurrence
entre les services gendarmes police etc
je sais que c'est que les événements qui
sont passés vont produire un sursaut
alors qu'en même temps où il a joué
simplement dit parce qu'on pose souvent
la question faut-il un fbi européen
honnêtement on peut le regretter mais en
l'état actuel dès textes et des traités
l'union n'a pas formellement de
compétences en matière de renforts mais
rien n'empêche de mes cadres
j'ai confiance je pense que je suis
assez volontariste mais était possible
2000 en sorte que les outils européens
soient alimentés et donc ça c'est la
première ici deuxième exercice c'est
d'encourager les services éventuellement
déjà entre eux
de travailler de manière plus structurée
il travaille entre je crois qu'il faut
pas laisser penser que la donne et que
les laisser me de renseignement ne
partage pas tous vos garanties qui
travaillent 24 heures sur 24 il n'y a
pas un chef de service de renseignement
qui est responsable ils sont tous qui
n'est pas obsédé par l'idée d'éviter à
nathan typhoon quand même sérieux c'est
pas d'argent c'est pas des gens léger et
il travaille beaucoup
la question n'est pas tellement celle là
c'est plutôt de passer moins ce que
j'appelle ça de manière un peu simple de
l'artisanat à l'industrie
mais je dois dire aussi que le club des
services de renseignement j'étais avec
eux il ya quelques jours ils sont en
train de se constituer une plateforme
commune le défi il sera ensuite en de
nouer un lien entre cette plate forme
commune et europol ouais et l'a donc du
coup jean arthuis il faut peut-être
espérer que je n'ai pas encore 20 ans
salut louis l'engagement de ceux de
kerchove
mais vous êtes au service du conseil
c'est à dire et celle des têtes gouverne
gouvernement et vos interlocuteurs sont
souvent des diplomates
plus que des politiques ne nous nous
sommes par le monde hier et et nous
devons dire avec force et proclamé qui a
nécessité de modifier les traités
maintenant on va pas continuer dans le
cadre mais vous savez elle ne sort pas
je veux dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
détenteur de la légitimité de la
compétence en matière de sécurité
intérieure celle états membres on ne va
pas aller faire une robe de la sécurité
contre les états mans il va bien falloir
les encourager et donc je trouve assez
la proche de gilles de kerckhove de dire
on fait tout pour encourager sachant
qu'il n'y a pas d'obligation au titre
des traités mais n'y a pas non plus
d'interdictions autrement dit tout ce
que les états veulent faire ensemble
rien ne l'interdît dans les traités donc
là on trial l'obligeant que je vais
prendre l'exemple de repos l'europole
rien n'était dit europol de recevoir du
renseignement et donc il y avait une
volonté politique
europol peut se mettent à recevoir du
renseignement et ils n'ont pas besoin
d'être bien européen pour la vie ou
alors c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'obligation
dans ce domaine là d'europe est une
obligation d'europe en matière de
schengen
voilà ce qu a pâti moment où lever les
contrôles au fonds deviendra la table et
politique lisait de visages et de plus
en plus d'assister ce merdier de
sécurité et c'était mon raisonnement
avec le pnr aussi je disais au parlement
européen joie bièvre vos objections en
matière de vie privée
mais si vous ne le faites pas qu'est ce
qui va se passer tous les états membres
se doter dans les nappes nerfs nationale
alors pourrait faire un le pen
r1 pour nous pour nos spectateurs c'est
donc un état fichier qui va recenser 19
informations votre nom votre prénom le
team les bagages
ça peut aller jusqu'à 34 qui est quand
même la plus grosse base de données
potentiellement sur le territoire
européen
donc effectivement ça pose des questions
non mais je voulais juste mon
raisonnement c'est que si le parlement
qui est quand même une institution
supranationale qui veut pousser à
l'intégration aurait eu comme paradoxe
en refusant le pnr europea qui est pas
vraiment européen on est d'accord mais
aurait eu comme paradoxe qu'on aurait eu
28 p nationaux on veut ça aurait été
moins efficace moins protecteur parce
qu'on sait bien que les niveaux de
protection étaient différents et moi je
remplis à ce corps était tout de même un
paradoxe alors justement à ce propos le
plr a donc été voté la semaine dernière
après des mois d'atermoiements voire des
années est ce que ça va changer quelque
chose d'avoir ce fichier est ce que cela
va véritablement empêché de nouveaux
attentats terroristes en ouvrant le pnr
et arrêtons de parler du pnr il s'agit
bien de vas-tu pnr à standard européen
peut-être passer le jour 28 pays
alors dire le pnl 28 pnr dans lesquelles
entre lesquels échanges d'informations
n'est pas obligatoire première chose
d'eux on nous vend l'outil comme un
outil d'identification d'accord or moi
je regarde les faits et les faits nous
disent eh bien ça fait dix ou quinze ans
que des attentats se commettent par des
gens qui sont identifiés pour l'immense
majorité d'entre eux ils sont identifiés
se sont pas des nouveaux venus
le pnr dans le cas dans les cas qui nous
occupe aurait servi à rien du tout et
donc moi je pose une question à gilles
de kerchove que je n'ai pas toujours
entendus enthousiaste du pnr qu'est ce
qui nous empêcherait d'avoir un système
de collecte
ciblez vous dit on à 5000 suspect donc
qu'est ce qui nous empêcherait d'avoir
un système de collecte ciblées et
souvent d'un judiciaire de donner un peu
d'air avec ça moi j'ai aucun problème
ce qu'on a maintenant c'est une collègue
généralisée et sans contrat que ça c'est
pas mon cap elle s'implique vraiment de
très 500 par une tête puissante en ont
parlé des moyens humains comment est-ce
qu'on traite autant de données jean
arthuis mais vous en prie moi j'ai voté
le pnr mais c'est un couteau sans manche
en effet ses 28 ans femme nerfs il ya le
feu dans la maison mais les états
membres disposent de deux ans pour
mettre en application cette
directive l'échangé d'information n'est
pas une obligation
alors néanmoins il offre une possibilité
de coopération entre certains états
membres
les règlements qu'exemple j'espère et
que certains parmi eux vont s'en saisir
ce qui est une confiance mutuellement en
eux puisqu'on me dis que dans certains
cas on ne veut pas et changer
automatiquement parce qu'il pourrait y
avoir des fuites d'informations donc au
moins il ya quelques états sûr et
j'espère que ce ces états là vont
pouvoir travailler rapidement sans parce
que si on laisse chacun développé son
propre logiciel et y aura-t-il une
parfaite compatibilité le jour jeudi
devant la nation va très vite revenir
avec une mesure d'application de la
directive en définissant des standards
communs donc je pense que techniquement
ce sera pas tellement le problème il
faut bien comprendre à quoi c'est le pn
et le pnh et ce n'est pas la solution à
tout je pense que si quelqu'un a dit ça
il en traite pas de quoi c'est la
solution en fait c'est pour pouvoir
détecter les mouvements suspects de
personnes qu'on n'aurait pas détecté à
travers le travail du renseignement de
terrain c'est à dire que à molenbeek ou
dans les banlieues françaises
mais de renseignement arrive à détecter
à travers leur travail normal des gens
qui se dirige vers la syrie et demain ça
peut être un dans cette année à la poche
non ils le font leur travail de terrain
ah non je dirais qu'il ya plus ou moins
30% qu'on ne parvient pas à détecter
nous avons maintenant nous allons
changer législation pour contrôler
systématiquement les européens mais en
fait le pnr sert à quoi
sur la base de ce que nous dit le
renseignement sur le profil moyen avant
gardiste du profane et c'est une sorte
de profiling mais absolument je ne dis
pas que j'ai mal dit mais vous savez que
julio mis ça pour effet de réduire le
profiling et je dirais le contrôle
ethnique
pourquoi parce qu'on ne se base pas sur
la couleur de la peau on se bat non sans
religion mais on se base sur des
conneries jol expliqué si je prends ne
considère pas que c'est nécessairement
les critères mais s'il les services de
renseignements vous dise le candidat
moyens et qui par an en eau-de-vie adore
en syrie c'est quelqu'un qui voyage sans
bagage prend son billet le dernier jour
est payant cash par exemple on vous
mettez ces trois indicateurs qui sont
franchement anodin on a bien là quand
ils vous les mettez dans votre
algorithmes et vous peignez des milliers
de
deux passagers vous sortez simplement la
liste de ceux qui ont plus ou moins ce
profil là
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'on les arrête
ça veut dire simplement que la la police
ce qui a trait au travail mais on s'y
intéresse
le type à la frontière à votre avis qui
fait quoi quand il voit passer les bus à
la tête du client
et bien justement ça réduit cette espèce
d'argot falling maintenant et donc ça me
paraît déjà très lente et leeds
rationnellement ça a l'air de tenir la
route maintenant les etats-unis ont un
pnr or je sais qu'au congrès des états
unis on demande au département de
l'intérieur tient au fait afin de la
sécurité intérieure tiens le pnr ça a
servi à quelque chose
et jusqu'à maintenant la réponse est pas
vraiment s'il avait un exemple s'il
avait un exemple où grâce à du profiling
il ait pu empêcher un attentat je suis
sûr qu'il serait sorti alors à l'agitée
avec un grand dans la pourriture et
dernier majeur artisanat nerfs c'est un
instrument un instrument ça n'est pas
forcément la solution
c'est un début de réponse mais c'est pas
ça il va nourrir la logique c'est on
collecte des informations sur tout le
monde on fait tourner dessus des
algorithmes pour identifier les
comportements déviants contre le
terrorisme dit bah oui c'est bien normal
quand nos données sortie avec la
surveillance généralisée des
télécommunications d'internet etc
on s'est tous dit skandal scandale mais
en fait c'est exactement la même logique
qui est à l'heure des grandes oreilles
et on les connaît donc on ne prétend pas
arriver tous les problèmes c'est un
instrument supplémentaire peut créer
avec ça je viens de poser très
clairement le principe d'un tel pays
européens il ya dix ans monsieur
fraudeurs et monsieur chirac en était
les promoteurs il s'est rien passé
depuis
donc j'espère que cette situation de
dramatique cette tragédie qui met de nos
opinions publiques en transe j'espère
que politiquement en vain tiré les
conséquences mais donc là moi je propose
puisque nous n'avons pas juridiquement
les compétences de le faire dans le
cadre institutionnel de l'union en tant
que fbi aux censeurs recueil de
renseignements monsieur renzi la
proposer monsieur michel l'a proposé
rien n'empêche les états membres à
l'avant du camion structuré et il faut
vous savez quand europol a été créée
vous savez comment ça s'est passé
c'est le chancelier kohl à la suite de
la chute du mur de berlin qui était très
préoccupé par la criminalité en
provenance de russie
et il a contre l'avis de son bk arrêt
contre l'avis de son ministre de
l'intérieur parce que c'était un homme
qui avait dîné d'or chip dont la
négociation de maastricht il a dit nous
allons le faire
personne ne savait ce que c'était à tous
l'accès pâlissante haricots et ça ce
serait alors une autre
il ya eu une autre conséquence à ces
attentats c'est le retour des contrôles
aux frontières a notamment la frontière
franco belge
on a voulu savoir un petit peu comment
se déroulaient ces contrôles renforcés
donc cia et le goujon qui s'est rendu
sur place
de mémoire de chauffeurs routiers on
n'avait pas vu ça depuis 20 ans ici
c'est souvent 20 à 30 minutes qu'on perd
à cause des embouteillages dus au
rétrécissement des voies pour passer la
frontière sous l'oeil des douaniers
français ont par contre depuis le
rétablissement des contrôles à la
frontière franco belge
le trafic routier est ralentie des
kilomètres de bouchons et au bout une
fouille aléatoire des cargaisons une
entorse à la libre circulation des
marchandises
les accords de schengen ont été signés
il ya maintenant 20 ans cette pme de
transport belge a vu son chiffre
d'affaires ça fléchir de 5% l'impact
pour nous disons chez si vous voyez
qu'un chauffeur prolé entre 9 et 10
heures 2 heures de travail qui perd à
peu près une demi heure par jour ça fait
à peu près de 5% environ 5 % de perte de
chiffre d'affaires ce restaurant routier
lui perd beaucoup plus ici les clients
ont déserté reste les voisins les
habitués les routiers sont un peu trop
occupés à passer la douane le midi en
veulent beaucoup de monde m'a
m'annonçait avec la bouche on
il a bu le temps de s'arrêter avec les
cantons ruraux qe2
les heures de route et nageurs de l'eau
font ça pour ça c'était quand même
maintenant rétablissement de la
frontière dans la foulée des attentats
de novembre à paris les contrôles se
sont accentuées au fil des semaines
crise migratoire
ça ali
t les 10
sont resserrés le nom des 620 km de
frontière nous sommes à warneton
de l'autre côté du pont la belgique si
les forces de l'ordre ne peuvent pas
tout contrôler et qu'il n'a jamais été
question de fermer les frontières carte
grise assurance est permis de conduire
les contrôles sont plutôt tatillon vous
pouvez ouvrir notre coffre s'il vous
plaît vous passez officier du couple
permis de conduire comme nous avaient
pas
en cinq mois près de 6 millions de
personnes ont dû montrer patte blanche à
l'entrée en france et dix mille se sont
vus interdites de territoire
certaines personnes étaient signalées
par les fiches
est ce que nous faisons en sorte aussi
d'avoir des contrôles avec un nombre
suffisant de gendarmes des gendarmes qui
sont armés d'armes
deux pistolets mitrailleurs pour être en
mesure de faire face à la menace qui est
aujourd'hui un niveau très élevé si du
côté français on affiche une volonté de
faire du côté belge on est moins
optimiste
en fait toute la frontière franco belge
faut bien se rencontrer ces missiles à
longue échéance est pas possible
pour ter oui en tout il existe mille 500
points de passage entre les deux pays
alors quand on leur pose la question les
habitants sont plutôt sceptiques sur
l'intérêt du dispositif
donc ils vont sur les grosses frontières
oui c'est sûr que c'est rassurant mais
je pense que quelqu'un qui veut passer
leurs frontières ils peuvent sans
problème
il ya trop de monde hier à la frontière
être large donc on peut on sait pas
mettre des gens d'un peu partout je
pense pas ou que vous au final celui qui
prépare bien son plan pour passer la
frontière pour les attentats je pense
il peut passer quoi honnêtement c'est ce
que je pense
routes autoroutes village mêmes canaux
la gendarmerie multiplie les modes
opératoires
ce qu'on recherche c'est ce type de
trafic donc sa lutte antiterroriste
comme le trafic de stupéfiants et
notamment pour le transport de personnes
marchandises à fait crucial c'est à un d
un des vecteurs
bonjour monsieur mettre votre confiance
votre destination
mais avec 60 contrôle par mois les
canaux reste un point de passage discret
ce n'est pas de contrôler repas sur
xboite alex a pas changé pour les
bateaux ça va changer
bon alors comme en belgique beaucoup de
contre eux en france on mais au final
surveiller les frontières est il
toujours une bonne stratégie
le lendemain des attentats salle
abdeslam et contrôlée par trois fois
avant de traverser la frontière
le tout sans être inquiété
alors philippe lambert je voyais qui est
cependant ce reportage diriez vous que
la frontière franco belge est une
véritable passoire gruyère finalement
qu'on est dans de la communication je me
rappelle juste après les attentats de
novembre à paris nous avions session à
strasbourg et la france avaient décidé
de fermer ses frontières et en effet il
y avait un barrage filtrant à la
frontière luxembourgeoise et donc pour
le retour je me suis dit je vais pas
passer par là j'ai passé par longwy est
là et donc c'était quatre jours après le
début de la session donc on n'est pas le
tien lundi on est revenu un jeudi et
donc avait absolument rien servir
on vous fermez stations de métro ont
fait entre
mais il ya personne pour contrôler dans
toute façon tout le monde s'en fout pays
fassent idée que en mettant un gendarme
tous les dix mètres on va à prévenir les
attentats je crois que c'est c'est un
petit peu une illusion savez il ya un
état qui surveille ses citoyens
massivement physiquement
électroniquement c'est la chine
ce qu'on observe qu'il ya des attentats
suicide en chine aussi donc se dire que
la sécurité absolue on va la voir et
grâce à ça c'est pas vraiment si vous
êtes d'accord
je pense que lorsque se produisent des
attentats et des drames que l'opinion
publique est en émoi et des pouvoirs
publics procèdent à des actions de
communication donc là pour vous les
dents de la communication clairement on
voit circuler dans les rues de bruxelles
des engins blindés ont remis leur
offrons aux tirs mais très franchement
on est dans la communication
le vrai sujet c'est que quand on a créé
l'espace schengen les états membres ont
tiré les bénéfices de l'opération c'est
à dire qu'ils sont supprimer des postes
douaniers
ceci a permis quelques fois de faciliter
le rééquilibrage relatif des budgets
mais on sait pas du tout préoccupé des
frontières extérieures là on appris en a
pris les dividendes de la suppression
des produits d'intérieur et on s'est pas
occupé du reste c'est là qu'il ya une
sorte de deux bévues collective et on a
dit voilà au nom de la souveraineté
nationale sont responsables ceux des
états qui ont des frontières extérieures
alors si ça vient par la grèce eh bien
c'est la grèce qui est responsable
et si ça vient par l'italie c'est
l'italie qui est responsable à la race
pro mais les collaborateurs à
disposition ils sont je le méritais de
la grèce par exemple on envoie des
douaniers français en grèce ils sont
sous l'autorité du gouvernement grec
alors j'ai le gars comme on est on est
au milieu du gué là avec schengen passé
il ya eu les bénéfices pour les états y
est le bénéfice pour l'économie c'est
tout à fait un formidable développement
économique qui s'en disent dans ma
jeunesse je dis simplement je dis
simplement qu'on n'a pas mis en place
aux frontières extérieures les moyens
appropriés s'avère un peu théorique mais
j'ai bien rappeler aussi qu'au fond
schengen c'est pas la libre circulation
des personnes paradoxalement schengen
c'est un projet de mesures
compensatoires la libère la liberté de
circulation étaient prévues par les
traités communautaires
ce fait schengen et c'est un projet qui
ne s'arrêtera jamais il faut le dire il
faut et quand je dis il faut plus de
chaînes y est ça veut dire plus de
mesures de contrôle aux frontières
extérieures donc tout à fait d'accord
mais les frontières intérieures donc ça
veut bien dire que la leur établissement
la frontière franco-belge déception mais
c'est en étant beaucoup plus vigilant en
frottait extérieur systématique
la commission a fait la proposition de
contrôler systématiquement les citoyens
européens parce que nous avons gelé dit
5000 à l'entrée du salon oui mais c'est
déjà un progrès parce que pour le moment
ce n'était pas le cas
et aussi la transformation de frontex en
un système de garde frontières européens
avec la possibilité se substitue un état
qui ne rempliraient pas les dans
l'instant mais pour l'instant ça c'est
l'état haïtien la frontière vers une
mutualisation c'est un processus qui
prend du temps et il faut tout le temps
raffinés se mesure qu'on pense à toi
c'est aussi l'échangé d'informations par
exemple un tiers de renseignement
c'était peut-être le hall et de démesure
compensateur schengen qui étaient les
moins développés et donc on va vers là
et ça ne s'arrêtera pas parce que la
criminalité va peut-être encore se
transformer celle de kaka vous qui êtes
du côté du conseil
la commission a mis sur la table une
proposition pour des gardes-côtes pour
des gardes-frontières sont quelle
autorité seront ils et quelle est
l'attitude du conseil en la circonstance
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de réponse
moi j'attends que on est une position
claire de la part du conseil sur une de
ces négociations et celle en négociation
mais on en fini mais alors est-ce qu'on
a tendance à voudrait dire qu'il faut
rétablir quoi qu'il arrive les
frontières aux fins dans schengen les
frontières intérieures je ne peux être
que temporaire c'est pour une période
limitée
s'il ya vraiment dangereux effet là en
l'occurrence devant la menace de death
est ce qu'il faudrait pas enfin c'est un
petit peu la période aux frontières
entre les états membres
c'est la vigilance à l'hôtel il va
falloir aussi qu'on apprenne à vivre
avec la menace la menace terroriste de
risque zéro n'existera pas aussi que
c'est assez confus et citoyens si on
veut être cru par nos concitoyens il
faut pas leur vendre du vent l'air les
faits je suis assez d'accord avec jean
arthuis quand eddie beaucoup d'action
dites de sécurité sont des actions de
communication et les citoyens réalisent
bien parce qu'il le voit sur le terrain
par contre je crois que nous devons
faire tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir
pour collecter les informations dont on
a besoin et surtout les exploitent et
moi je suis un peu inquiet quand je vois
qu'on va aller
m un demi milliard dans les 28 pnr quand
on sait la pauvreté de la police de
proximité souvent c'est le renseignement
terrain qui va faire la différence je là
dessus on a désinvesti quand même dans
tous les éléments qu de moyens humains
et le calme ça je suis totalement
d'accord
donc là je suis aussi d'accord qu'il
faut bien envoyer le message aux
populations que le risque zéro n'existe
pas mais sur le travail de terrain moi
je les encourage c'est pas simplement la
police de proximité se gérer tous les
tous les acteurs de première ligne et
formés à détecter par exemple les signes
du trésor apporté des réponses non
sécurité voilà des jeunes
oui cette affaire de la prévention dans
toutes mes interventions
il est toujours à volet sécurité mais
j'insiste énormément sur le volet de
prévention kfy là on doit faire beaucoup
plus a supposé moyens et est pour
l'instant les moyens où sont les
finalités de l'air plupart des états
membres
c'est un vrai sujet et dont
l'affaiblissement pas nos économies en
fait mort et les frontières intérieures
et bien ce sera le mot de la fin
messieurs de la vigilance merci merci à
vous d'avoir accepté de débattre sur
cette question voilà c'est la fin de
cette émission vous pouvez l'avoir bien
entendu sur notre site internet vous
pouvez réagir et commenter sur les
réseaux sociaux la semaine prochaine
vous retrouver ahmed tazir ici à cette
place ciao